welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B now Jessica Clements and I were
lucky to go see a sneak peek of neon's
new film infinity pool the other day I'm
not usually a horror guy but Jessica
loves the scary stuff she dragged me
along and I gotta say this movie was
visually crazy stunning okay it's got
that Cronenberg Legacy David
cronenberg's son Brandon directed the
thing I gotta be honest you gotta see it
to believe it it has Alexander Skarsgard
if you like handsome Vikings Mia goth
She's creepy but in a weird way very
beautiful not that looks are everything
it's but it's inside that counts and if
you like insides you're gonna see a lot
of blood and guts in this movie now what
do you say Mia should people go see this
movie